pas mal réagir y avait une candidate
catherine il ya surpris cristina cordula
car à la porter une tenue qui a laissé
entrevoir un petit quelque chose et
regarder ça a énormément parlé là dessus
vous savez de quoi je peux parler
regardez ouais non pas d'éléphants
pointe roque c'est un peu chaud oui il
n'y a pas que ça qui est chaud mais ce
pas cristina on a là avec les bras pour
aller comme ça c'est pas possible et 4 à
7 1 façon ne faut pas hésiter de ck one
pollution visuelle
alors est ce que vous êtes contre les
poils sous les bras oui alors justement
sur cette séquence jeu j'ai été choqué
par ce que christine corps du climat
cordula elle n'a pas été démago et elle
a dit vraiment ce qu'elle pensait alors
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien top
ben c'est homme qu'elle dit ce qu'elle
pense mais par contre il faut dire pour
ma part parce qu'il ya plein de femmes
qui laissent pousser leurs poils et qui
trouvent ça normal et qui ont envie de
liberté qui se laissent pousser les
poils mais je pense qu'alors a dit elle
elle aurait dû dire pour ma part ma dire
c'est un fashion faux pas bull il ya des
gens qui se laissent guider vous laisser
pousser vous avez déployés mais moi rien
je déteste les poils
d'accord vous ce jour non moi non plus
mais à la fois
moi je passais contre les diktats voilà
progrès que non non elle dissertation
faux pas elle parle même pas d'hygiène
ou quoi que ce soit ou d'esthétisme
elle vient fashion faux pas l'arrière
avec la mode vous êtes aussi vous avez
des cols bleus sous les bras
non j'ai pas de poils sous les bras mais
je respecte celle qui en nous et je
dirais pas que sa fâcheuse faudra je
dirais que pour ma part je trouve que
c'est c'est pas assez pas esthétique
mais que ça peut plaire à d'autres et je
le respecte mais je dirais bras là sur
un acte politique et féministe médecins
masculins ils sont contre les diktats
imposés par les hommes d'épilation qui
on se laisse pousser par les bras c'est
nous qui sommes urnes notre corps nous
appartient on fait ce qu'on veut de
julia roberts l'avait fait mais tapis
rouge d'aller récemment sevenier le
revers aussi parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
peinture de poils
gilles queille c'est vrai que maintenant
je fais des cta curie aux tout ça mais
moi je suis pour la liberté je trouve
que même dans sa main la sur sa tête
cristina cordula l'air de stigmatiser
c'est ça qui m'a gêné je suis sur les
deux mois sous les bras
l'annoncé d'une histoire m'a mec qui
trouvaient que qui adorez les poils ils
interdisaient de lens il a prouvé sa
bonne femme de ce2 se raser les poils et
il fit lui me fait même des trucs pour
que ça pousse incompétence et orientale
a été bien voulu bienvenue la plaquer
pour une femme absolument sans poils
je sais combien je me souvienne ce
papier dans le parisien là dessus ces
salles on sait ça d'anecdotes oui bah
moi ça m'a tellement fait rire quand
elle a vu ça nous a bien fait